Sáng 22 tháng 6 đã trụ sở bộ cuối phòng, bài tướng phòng văn dàng, bởi viên bộ chính trị, bỏ thu đứng chính phủ bộ cuối phòng.
Mà tiếp xa rao quyền bộ trưởng bộ hải quyền hoặc ki luôn cao.
Bài tướng phòng văn dàng trước mừng quyền bộ trưởng bộ hải quyền hoặc ki luôn cao,
được bộ nhiễm cương vị quan trọng và tinh tưởng dàng trên cương vị trọng chát của mình sẽ tiếp tục chỉ đạo.
Tụi đại hơn nữa tắc cuối phòng sau phương nhất là trong lĩnh vực ăn ninh biển,
nóng có tích cửa cho các hệ trụng của hai nước.
Thời giám tới trên cơ sở các văn bản thật hận đã kí kết,
đại dướng phòng dàng mong muốn hải bên tiếp tục xin 2 hiệu của ăn nổi dùng hật tắc.
Tật trụng và các lĩnh vực như cháu đường ăn các cấp,
đạo ăn ninh biển, có người phòng phòng tắc quân biển trụng,
với tinh thần các lại quá khớn, dưỡng tới tương lai,
tiếp tục con trọng và yêu diên hật tắc và khắc khu khẩu quả chính trách.
Quên bộ trưởng bộ hai quân hoặc ki cà mơn tại tướng phòng ăn dàng và bộ cuối phòng Việt Nam đã dành thời gian tiếp đoàn.
Đồng thời đánh giá cao hợp tắc cuối phòng Việt Nam hoặc ki thời gian qua được trình khá hiệu qua.
Thế thực của hợp với quan hệ trụng giá ai nước,
và hoặc bộn thời gian tới 2 bên tiếp tục xối hợp,
thúc đại hợp tắc trong lĩnh vực ăn ai.
Nhân dịp này, tại tướng phòng rất vừa đợi mời và hoàn lên hoặc ki cuối quan trích,
vui như cuối phòng tham dự và trình bây giờ sản thẩm tại khi làm cuối phòng cuối tế Việt Nam là thứ 3 và tháng mê hai sắp tới tại hà nội.